[upbeat music]
[cheers and bells ringing]
[drumming]
[band plays fanfare]
♪
[cheering]
To the students
of the Class of 2023
and their parents
families and friends.
Welcome to the 322nd
commencement of Yale University.
We salute your effort,
your diligence, your talent
and your intellect.
I now ask you
by your official act,
to confer upon them
these degrees.
[cheers and applause]
By the authority vested in me,
I confer upon you
the bachelor's degrees in Yale
College,
as designated by the Dean
and admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities.
♪
[cheers and applause]
I have the honor to present
candidates for degrees
in the David Geffen
School of Drama,
in the School of Architecture,
in the School of Nursing
[cheering]